one of the most asked questions I saw
from folks is just how are you
personally navigating the crisis
financially like what are you buying
what are you selling where are you
watching where you think opportunities
on the investment side I mean I've been
lucky like my entertainment businesses
have got crushed
I mean I'll lose I'm lucid shitload of
money there right just crushed but you
know I was lucky that my core holdings
were Netflix and Amazon and so you know
I'm that's kind of balancing some things
out so I'm fortunate there but it you
know I still I'm going to cash the
market's going up and there's good
reasons why the markets going up right
for all the good things I that we just
talked about right you know three years
five years from now the market will be
up from where we are today it will be up
you know who knows how much but it will
it'll be better um but I still think we
have a leg down and so I've gone to cash
and if even if not in the public markets
if I'm wrong in the public markets I
think there's going to be companies that
need capital in this in this America 2.0
that are going to be what we just talked
about right there's gonna be when we
look back in ten years there's gonna be
some amazing companies that were created
and having access to cash or having cash
is gonna give me the opportunity to
invest in them and like I said I'm super
excited about that I don't know who it's
gonna be but if you got it bring it to
me
forget Bitcoin for a second let's just
stick with other non public assets
anything around bold land commodities
anything in there um I think commodities
would go up because I think we'll get at
least some modicum of inflation and as
companies to kind of try to protect
their own manufacturing and try to
really bring core core necessities
domestically I think that could push up
the value of commodities I couldn't tell
you which ones to invest in but just
generically and on a macro basis um I'm
not a big gold fan i analogize that more
to Bitcoin and um just because what are
you going to do right we saw it all hit
the fan and there ain't nobody walking
around with gold
there ain't nobody asking for pavement
and gold and we're pretty money as fast
as we can and things aren't deflating or
inflating at least not yet right and so
there's I don't see that as being a
solution we saw what
- oil right and so manufacturers you
know can come in or the drillers in this
case Saudi Arabia and Russia the leaders
can come in just turn them industry
upside down and the same thing can
happen with gold you know so what about
on the real estate side anything there
yeah I mean I'm looking right I'm trying
to be opportunistic and agile not
necessarily to take advantage of
people's misfortune but um I just think
that there'll be a lot of reformulating
because there's so many there's so many
companies that were leveraged you know
so companies went to go buy land or
buildings or shopping centers whatever
it may be and they put down very little
capital and they went out and borrowed
more and you know then they sold that
you know and the lenders so that the
tranches and you know they're I think
you're gonna see some deleveraging there
which creates some opportunities to buy
land but you're not seeing all those
discounts yet except in big dense cities
that have had the but like um like New
York you're starting to see condos the
prices there just drop like a rock so if
you think you want to live in New York
in the future now's the time to buy you
know if you think you want a house in an
area that's been hit hard
you know Detroit or wherever it may be
now's the time to buy so I think in for
personal purposes it's a good time to if
you have cash to buy real estate for
sure NBA obviously he's gonna come back
at some point let me say one other
things in terms of investment okay on
college right
you gotta rethink where you're going to
school and whether you're gonna borrow
money at all and colleges themselves you
got to make sure your college isn't
going to go out of business because
they're sources of revenue and just gone
they're gone right they dried up like
that you know a lot of colleges made
their money off of international
students coming in and paying full ride
in terms of tuition and room and board
they can't get in the country you know
and if they get it in they might not be
able to get out and they may not have
the capital you know or being able to
afford and so you're gonna see a lot of
rejiggering of universities public and
to a lesser extent you
the Ivy League schools are going to be
okay because their endowment but below
that you know you're gonna see a lot of
reformat in a lot of rethinking and who
knows when students go back and so if
your school was going to have you have
was going to force you to do online
learning anyways why are you gonna pay
for a full credit when you can go into
any of the other online sources we go to
Coursera and learn the same stuff for
free and then try to test out or go to a
local community college and then go test
out or transfer your credits so beware
that college is dirt economics are
changing so dramatically that the world
is going to be different if you're one
of those who wanted to go to that school
because it's got a great football or
basketball team they may not be playing
anyways and it's not going to be as
social fraternities sororities are going
to have to rethink everything dorms
you're gonna have to rethink everything
and so we talked about going to arenas
think about going back to school it's
not just about going to class or watch a
class where you gonna live you know
there's just so many elements involved
in college life that are going to change
that party probably the after some of
the entertainment industries one of the
the most negatively impacted industries
is going to be schools universities and
as a potential student as a current
student you need to look at this as the
biggest investment you're gonna make
over the next 10 15 years and really
re-evaluate what your choice is worth
yeah the cent that I saw was the average
calculus one course in America in person
2,500 bucks online $400 reasons to write
it so at the school you want to go to
you can test out go take it on course
there or whatever and just try to test
out you know and then that's the same
with jobs two-man jobs are going to be
completely different what are you gonna
do for your first job you're gonna take
any job because you're not trying to get
a career you're a free agent right and
that free agent you're he's gonna pay
your bills you just want to have some
liquidity you want to have some
semblance of normalcy and competence in
your financial future and then as you
learn and look you just paid for college
now you're getting paid to learn when
you get to that first job even if it's
the worst job ever you're gonna learn
what you don't like and then go from
there and you start bouncing from job to
job to job till you get to one you love
where you look you
figure out that there's something in
this job you don't realize you love but
now you love but take your the way you
approach your job life is gonna be
completely different yeah getting paid
to learns the better than pain to learn
for sure